[Musique]
nous mettons fin à la libre circulation
pour ouvrir la grande bretagne au monde
cela permettra de garantir que les gens
pourront venir dans notre pays
en fonction de ce qu'ils ont à offrir et
non d'où ils viennent
[Musique]
les conservateurs se précipite sur ce
projet de loi qui constitue un risque
énorme pour nos soignants ainsi que pour
tout le secteur des soins pendant la
crise du coronavirus franchement cette
hypocrite vis-à-vis des 180 milles
soignants et travailleurs sociaux que de
les applaudir les jeudis soirs pour leur
dire maintenant qu'ils ne sont pas les
bienvenus ici et pour les amis
journalistes rt uk ce nouveau projet de
loi pourrait déséquilibrer l'économie
britannique
il ya des pressions sur le gouvernement
britannique pour qu'il maintienne sa
posture anti union européenne même en
pleine épidémie due coronavirus on l'a
vu le gouvernement britannique a refusé
de prendre part à un programme d'achat
commun qui aurait aidé le royaume uni à
obtenir du matériel vital est difficile
à obtenir des équipements de protection
personnelle
cela aurait aidé les travailleurs du
système de santé britannique dans leur
lutte contre le coc ville 19 mai le
gouvernement britannique s'est abstenu
et beaucoup au royaume uni l'ont accusé
d'avoir subi en raisonnement purement
politique
c'est la même position anti européenne
que l'on retrouve maintenant matière
d'immigration
certains redoute que la restriction de
l'immigration et des conséquences
négatives sur l'économie
certains redoute que la restriction de
l'immigration et des conséquences
négatives sur l'économie
sur le reste du pays dans certains
secteurs il y aura des critères indiqués
dans ce projet de loi qui vient d'être
acceptée en première lecture à la
chambre des communes
les aspirants à l'immigration
vont gagner des points un bon niveau
d'anglais un contrat avec un employeur
agréé rapporteront des points tout comme
un salaire d'au moins 25 1600 livres par
an ce qui est un salaire très élevé même
pour l'économie britannique
le système de santé britannique dépend
largement de l'immigration afin de
pourvoir ses effectifs une immigration
européenne mais également
extra-européenne mais c'est aussi le cas
d'autres secteurs le bâtiment où
l'agriculture nous avons pu le voir avec
la crise du coronavirus des avions ont
été affrétés spécifiquement afin
d'amener des travailleurs de roumanie
pour la récolte au royaume uni les
agriculteurs redoutent même alors que
l'économie ne va pas bien et qu'il n'y a
pas beaucoup d'emplois de ne pas trouver
un nombre suffisant de travailleurs
prêts à effectuer les durs labeurs
agricole auparavant ces secteurs vous
courez à des travailleurs étrangers lors
de la campagne du référendum on a vu
apparaître une rhétorique nativistes qui
se retrouve aujourd'hui dans les
politiques le gouvernement déclare
vouloir d'emploi pour les britanniques à
mais dans ces secteurs se payer peu
qualifiés les employeurs craignent de ne
pas trouver de britannique prêt à
effectuer le travail à moins d'augmenter
les salaires et même dans ce cas il n'y
aurait pas de garantie est donc possible
que le gouvernement abaisse le seuil
salarial nécessaires à l'obtention d'un
visa
il n'est pas du tout certain que des
britanniques puissent pour voir ces
emplois ou même qu'il le souhaite le
gouvernement sera sous une pression
continue d
secteurs de l'agriculture du bâtiment de
la restauration de l'hôtellerie afin que
le projet de loi soit modifiée avant
d'être finalement adopté